each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
let's get started so I'm happy to
introduce Benjamin Lipschitz Benjamin is
a student or Monaco lamb at Stanford and
you just defended his thesis a few
months ago so a few years ago a few
weeks okay dr. Lipschitz thank you um
and you know he's incredibly productive
guy I think he published like 11 papers
last year so he'll try and tell you
about some of them and some of his work
on improving software security in the
next iron r square um thank you for the
introduction and thank you all for
coming here so computer security has
attracted the great deal of attention in
recent years and not a bit goes by that
we don't hear about in your
vulnerability being discovered or a
website broken into and as you can see
from this graph there is no sign of
decline as far as the number of
vulnerabilities is concerned so this is
something we get from the nice database
now according to this quote from the
gardening group most of the
vulnerabilities out there happen at the
application level at the higher level as
opposed to the network level over
seventy percent of all attacks that they
studied in fact happen at the
application level now once this even
though this is clear it wasn't really
entirely on obvious to us what kind of
vulnerabilities were most common so we
decided to go and study this equation
for ourselves so I went to this website
security for goose com that collects
vulnerability reports and collect the
sample of about one big one week's worth
of vulnerability reports so about 500
vulnerability reports total and this is
how they can be classified so what you
can see here choose their pointer
does this work not so much okay can you
play with us so as you can see from this
by far the most common issue or the most
common category vulnerabilities oh great
by far the most common category all
neurologists are ones that come from
input voltage so they account for more
than fifty percent of all the
vulnerabilities in this sample now when
we narrow down on just those
vulnerabilities this is the picture we
get ok so again there are many different
sort of subcategories in this group and
the infamous buffer overrun issue comes
in a distant third and essentially all
of them well most of the other issues or
issues specific to web application so
you see issues with fancy sounding names
here like sequin Jackson cross-site
scripting attacks and the like now you
might be wondering what is the one
Junction so let me just show you yeah go
that way did you go order back all right
I guess one of the reason i ask is i
would assume that for example when
someone figures out a new vulnerability
there tend to be a rash of attacks right
and so are you looking at a flip that
happens the fit well with the thesis
you're trying to attack or is this
actually representative of
Croston yeah well good question it's
pretty representative that's the belief
now the exact numbers will differ quite
a bit actually depending on what source
you go to us we look at several
databases if the numbers vary from maybe
almost sixty percent with so in this
case to seventy percent 255 and so on so
I'm not claiming these to be so the most
accurate numbers but at the same time I
think it's pretty much a trend and most
of the things here are pretty much
stabilized as you'll see shortly now let
me talk about the sequel injection
vulnerability so I have an example here
of a web form when inside somewhere ok
and the dye Jake and web form is that so
the user enters his login and password
and then there is a java j2ee web
application beneath you know on the
server here serving these requests and
within the application you might have a
piece of code that looks like that so
you have a way to get the username from
the formal here I can't point it ok
there the username over here the
password over here and then there's a
sequel query that is constructed by
using string concatenation over here and
then finally the last step in this
process is that this query is being
submitted the backend database for
processing again so far so good now
suppose Bob comes along and enters Bob
that Bob's password and that makes it
into the application and the server this
is the query wheel gap ok and then Bob
click Submit and he gets his information
back so this is looking up his account
details as i make about same server ok
so far so good nothing now suppose I
come along it's a malicious hacker and
try this ok so enter Bob a Pacific
double dash now what you need to know is
that in the listing the Oracle dialect
of sequel double deth indicates the
beginning of a comment so it's actually
the rest of this command that is going
to be pastor their database for
execution is going to be effectively
ignored so I click Submit okay i get
Bob's information so without knowing can
you think about Bob's password I was
able to pretty easily get at his
a private data now suppose I'm even more
evil than before so I come along and I
type this type the same okay now this
goes this is the query that's
constructed that goes into the backend
database now when the sequel database
interprets this stuff is going to
essentially look at it as two separate
sequel queries the first one is going to
select and the second one will execute
this command which is a command that do
is the users table well as you can
probably see by now nothing good is
going to come out of this now to
summarize basically by controlling the
input that goes into the application i
was able to both or get at private
detail for user and also to you know
remove and effect data that's stored in
the database now sequel injection is
just is but one of many our web
application exploitation techniques that
exist out there there's a whole range of
them so some of them are shown over here
and all of them have these fancy
sounding names now fortunately for us
there is quite a bit of structure in
this picture so there's a easy way to
classify these all of these web
applications are attack techniques turns
out that some of them have to do with
how malicious data is injected into
application so there are several of
those and they are treated as central
taint sources in this case and then
there are several ways to exploit this
malicious data once it's made its once
it's in the database I'm sorry in the
application itself so any particular
vulnerability anybody could explore it
is essential combination of these two it
it's like a menu right you get something
from the first category like parameter
manipulation and parameter manipulation
is essential changing fields of a web
form and you've got the second part
which is sequel injection in this case
which is what I described just now and a
combination of these two gives you about
my ability
now to go back to your quiet against
question actually are these are issues
these vulnerabilities have a British
short but very illustrious history so I
actually went back and tracked down the
first report about cross-site scripting
goes back to year two thousand you know
and then sequin Junction is around the
same time and so on and then there are
some sort of more fancy forms of attacks
it appeared look at it later on now
despite having a British short history
there's there's been a number of very
important exploits that go along these
lines let me give you just a little
snapshot of some of them so these issues
go back only a few months the most
recent one is in May 2006 which was I
think a warm that was in the yahoo email
system now there are also financial
impact numbers that are associated with
you know these exploits and the average
course per incident is estimated to be
more than 300,000 and the total cost of
the you know of the overall cost of
online fraud is estimated to be 400
billion a year with the B so this is a
pretty what I'm trying to say here to
take you a message here is that this is
a big practical problem that is
effective that is affecting a lot of
applications all there on a daily basis
now with this being a big practical
problem they've been some solutions
developed so let me go over a couple of
the fu of these actually so the first
solution you can think of probably is
client-side input validation so there's
this a bit of JavaScript sitting in the
browser checking the values so this is
fine but unfortunately this is not
entirely effective because you know an
attacker might just be able to craft an
HTTP package rather and send it directly
to the application so this is easy to
circumvent doesn't work so well now the
next solution that's used in practice is
penetration testing essentially it's a
black box testing approach that requires
it
person to come up with potential
malicious inputs in order to the crash
exploit the application now as any
testing technique it's missing
vulnerabilities so we don't consider it
as effective generally speaking um the
next technique that is commonly used is
something that's called application
firewalls so several companies out they
are making devices of this nature so an
application firewall essentially is a
piece of hardware that sits on the line
and listens for packets that appear
malicious so it is to be able to
understand HTTP and so forth but it's
essentially kind of an intrusion
detection sort of system and as any such
system it suffers from both false
positives and false negatives so we
don't like it so much now the final
approach which we like lot is code
reviews but the problem is that code
reviewers don't like it so much
themselves right so this takes I mean
this is an effective technique but it
takes a lot of manual effort and hard to
scale and so forth and applications of
course change quite a bit and so you
need to go back now we'd like to
automate the code review process having
said that let me move on to describing
of describing what my work is about so
we call this the Griffin project this is
kind of a catch-all term for the work in
web application security we've been
doing so far so I'll talk about I'll
give you an overview of the project i'll
talk about static analysis and some
extensions they're off then i'll talk
about random technology and give you
some experimental results incomplete
okay so this is how it works the user
starts with a specification over the
vulnerability of vulnerabilities so they
need to tell us what they're looking for
and the application bytecode so this is
typically java bytecode these two things
are given by the user based on that
there is a static analysis being
generated automatically based upon the
specification this is something that was
first described in our gooseneck
security baby 2004
and the static analysis runs and gives
weldability warnings now there are
several advantages of this approach
which is it is able to find
vulnerabilities early in the development
cycle so that's great now it explores
all program potential program execution
so it doesn't require any inputs I mean
any test inputs anything like that
that's also great and finally the
approach is sound which means that it's
guaranteed to find all the vulnerability
of the sort we're looking for now a
significant disadvantage is that static
analysis might suffer from imprecision
so it might introduce false positives
now since that's the case we also have
an alternative runtime approach so
runtime approach the dynamic analysis
that was first described now so 2005
paper essentially takes the application
bytecode and instruments it with respect
is vulnerability specification okay so
we get an instrumented application that
drunk runs alongside others and a
standard application server and
advantages here is that it's essentially
not fixing the problems at the core but
it's able to prevent them from doing
harm ok now another advantage is that it
can recover from exploits as they happen
in real time as I'll discuss and it
doesn't have false positives unlike
static approach unlike the static
approach now the disadvantage is that
there's an overhead associated with our
time instrumentation of course in order
to reduce the overhead we also have a
feedback loop of fuel from the static
analysis so there's additional static
information being computed that reduces
the amount of instrumentation that needs
to be inserted and so that's been quite
effective in practice a question
I was one instance these are more
effective applications with this record
at all yeah so the overhead numbers can
be well the very but they can arrange
for about forty percent to about one
hundred twenty percent for the for the
naive version for the sort of reduced
instrumentation version drops down to
oftentimes to below ten percent drops
down to single digits oftentimes but
i'll have graphs that show you show that
besides these are interactive
applications you pointed out the
overhead is not a significant of a
problem oftentimes okay so let me speak
to the issue of soundness I might be
preaching to the choir but let me make
this point nevertheless now there's been
a lot of work in a bog finding
technology and reason here so here are
some of the projects you know just a few
of them now they go off the bus like
when technology references performance
areas memory leaks and data races and so
on and the goal there is to fix and find
common bugs that are likely to exhibit
exhibit themselves in the field now our
approach is our position of your bill is
slightly different all goal is to find
and fix all problems and we believe that
this is especially important when it
comes to critical issues of security
like I mentioned before the cost of a
single exploit can be very hard and
therefore its debt much more important
to be able to make guarantees on the
results of the analysis instead of just
making a best-effort attempt and I'll
come back to this now let me go back to
that example that I had before of a
sequel injection let me tell you a
little bit about what happens within the
application as it's running so this is a
conceptual picture so what happens is
that we get some data from the form by
calling survey the get parameter and
this acts as a pain source okay so this
is unsafe information flow also called
game flow of intact
and then there could be a string
concatenation happening and then there
could be another string operation and so
on and at some point this process will
hear the cemeteries at which point this
path will stop now I should point out
perhaps that strings in Java or objects
so each of these things is a separate
object on the heat now could there could
be another pass going right like this
one over here and eventually treat it
reaches a sink so once we have a direct
path from a source to the sink over here
so the source is something that comes
from a web form and the sink is
something that goes to the database we
have a drug test and therefore we have a
potential security violation okay now
initial question here as it says is how
do we know what all these parameters are
how do you know what this red it is and
this method and so what what are these
components well we don't that's in part
why we need the specification so the
user needs to tell us what to look for
the user needs to specify where the
source methods are sync methods
derivation methods which allow us to
connect one object to the next as well
as a musician routines and the way this
specification is provided is by means of
big wall so big wall is also something
described in oulu 2005 paper and it's it
stands for a program query language now
Pig will is a pretty general language
for describing sort of many properties
of events that happen on related objects
I think that's the most generic squish
exists description i can come up it now
we found it particularly useful for are
talking about security vulnerabilities
so what I happen this light here is a
very simple ah query that looks for
sequel injections it doesn't find all
psycho injections of course but it looks
for two though some types of them okay
so this is the queer declaration returns
these two objects which is kind of the
source in the sink in this case and well
I'm not going to go through this but you
can sort of hopefully map it back to the
coat hat in the original application
before now I should point out that I'd
like I said before this is just an
example a real people three reasons are
a bit longer than this they are usually
about 150 lines of people code and
they're designed to capture all sorts of
vulnerabilities not just the sequel
injections now the advantage well or
pickups a saving grace we have here is
that once we write the query like this
in piqua this query is going to be
suitable for pretty much any application
written to the j2ee standard okay so
basically the amount of additional
specification one has to do for new
application is relatively minor yep
right of the user makes a mistake in the
specification also absolutely absolutely
i'll speak to that very shortly now
having a sort of outline the structure
of the system let me talk about the
static analysis are aspect of it in more
detail let me sort of jump right into it
let me get right to the point so suppose
you have a piece of code like this okay
so there are a few lines separating
these two chunks of code so first you
get a user name from from the web form
you added to list and then you get
something from a different list and you
pass it to execute query you see so this
is an example but you see pieces of code
like this all the time now the question
is what objects do these variables
username and sgr refer to a point to
okay the question is of course relevant
because if they might point to the same
object then we might have a
vulnerability in this case now what
answer this question is a point analysis
and point analysis has been a subject of
a great deal of research in the last one
years or so and in particular the flavor
of point analysis that we take advantage
of here is the one developed now group
and described in the bill GI 2004 paper
now this is a context-sensitive
inclusion based point analysis which
these two things are there to increase
the precision of orbit as I'll discuss
shortly
now conceptually what happens is that
there's a runtime heap right and we have
some strings and that objects sitting on
the heap what the point analysis does is
that it provides the abstraction or a
static approximation what's going on at
runtime so in particular what might
happen is that these two these three
objects are 10 ton and all three might
map to the same object the same static
representation or the age so this
represents a collision on imprecision
important analysis so whenever a
precision such as this is introduced it
can lead it may lead to false positives
which we don't really like at all and
what we end up doing is we end up
developing a bunch of features of the
point now that we built into point
analysis that increases position okay I
think I said that now there's been a
variety of different point analysis
techniques suggested so we start
essentially with the baseline of a fully
context and sensitive point analysis
that general bit in precise now we can
add context sensitivity on top of it
i'll discuss what it is shortly and
that's the diversion we use is described
in bill 2004 paper that's still not
enough we end up eating object
sensitivity improvements on top of that
and we also have a flavor of map
sensitivity all of which will be
discussed very shortly so this is kind
of our letter of precision of yoga ok so
the context sensitivity this is kind of
the standard example of why it's
necessary right so we have a to take it
to two values coming can into this
function ID that just returns its
parameter so the first value stated the
second one is not if we pay attention to
what the context are will return this
value to the first context and sort of
the appropriate value the second context
they'll be known precision every budget
will be happy now if you have believe is
the context information of course will
be less happy because we all have to
conservatively conclude that this value
might retain so what happens is that
imprecision point analysis leads to
excessive painting and that leads to
false positive so that's something we
would like to avoid as much as possible
now in terms of in terms of point
analysis this is
something that can be formulated by the
points to relation is typically
described as relation between a variable
and a static representation of heap
object so these are the domains here and
this is the context insane stipulation
now context-sensitive version of this is
the simulation augmented with a context
over here so essentially parameterize it
by context now unfortunately for us well
while this is still this is much more
precise than before unfortunately for us
this is still not precise enough what we
want so continue this example we're here
so suppose you have two strings
allocated over here and you have two
maps map one in map to say so you
proceed to put to put the first change
into the first map and the second string
into the second map and then you proceed
to retrieve something from the second
map so of course what you want to get
from static analysis is that only the
second scene could be potentially tube
from the second map but we're not so
lucky so the context NC point analysis
will conclude that either of those
strings could build tree moreover if you
think about that any string that might
have been put in to any map declared
anywhere in the program will be
potentially coming out of this map so
this is grossly in precise we don't like
that at all it actually kills the
precision of our analysis pretty much
completely so remember this was the
context sensitive point analysis
formulation over here well fortunately
for us there is a object sensitive point
analysis formulation that was proposed
several years ago by other researchers
and so the good way to think about the
conceptual is that it parameterize
instead of the context number it permit
Rises this points to release by what the
this object in the method where V is
declared is pointing okay now this is
just one flavor of objects and security
areas
their orders so for instance this is
something that's called one level object
sensitivity so there are two hip objects
by which this relation is parameterized
on the variable and there is one on the
heap we might imagine still more precise
version of versions of point analysis
such as this which combines our context
sensitivity with the with one level
objects in Syria to be here for now this
is great I mean this is amazingly
precise point analysis we like it so
much and it works and gives us perfect
results on the small benchmarks that you
write it over now there is that's the
good news the bad news is that it
doesn't scale to anything beyond about
well about 300 closest is set now in
Java your hello world program is about
250 classes so you can sort of imagine
that this is not the most scalable
technique so we had to get around this
somehow so the approach we use is one of
cole graff judicious cole graff inlining
okay so the idea here is that if you
learn selected allocation sites it will
give you much more precision and they
kind of know what they're in line for
the most part so we know that the
internal presentation of container such
as hash map vector linked lists and so
on has to bend wine the same applies to
strength factors like string to lower
case and so on and the precision of this
in line of technique is essentially
giving gassings results that equivalent
to those obtained through objects and
security again this is the good news the
bad news is that well first of all we
need to know what to in line we cannot
really in line everything that's just
impossible so and we have this tension
right we if we in line two little will
get false positives we don't like that
if you in line too much the resulting
program will be just wait way too large
for us to analyze successfully so it
doesn't scale so what we have is
effectively is an iterative process
where we sort of choose targets for
inlining and if it doesn't give us
precise enough results been in line some
more well there's still
news2 comes which is in the presence of
recursion there is no particularly good
way to do in line inc and when we have
virtual methods with more than one
target it's also in lining as possible
but it's a bit of a challenge so those
are kind of the things that go against
the skin a little bit but still pretty
effective as you'll see now let me talk
about the last precision improvement
that we implemented as part of a static
analysis without sort of point analysis
phase of aesthetic analysis of email so
consider an example like this so we have
a username over here that is obtained
from a form then we put it inside of a
nap over here and then we proceeded to
get it to get something I'm sorry from
the same map okay and then we pass it to
the same color here that we don't like
so much now the point analysis will
happily conclude that since these
objects have been placed inside the same
map well they might be late it therefore
we have flow from over here down to here
so it will report report potential
vulnerability curative a liability in
this case but as you can plainly see
here there is really no connection
between these two keys right so you the
name is not equal to search query they
have no relation to each other there is
no need why we need to there is no
reason why we need to have flow between
these two things so turns out that this
is not just a single example right this
is something that is actually happening
quite often enlarge java application so
this is kind of a poor man's version of
structs where you have a constant string
and you associate values with that
constant string and then you retrieve
something back from the map at a later
point in the program so we decided to
just do these constant stream stuff in a
separate manner so what we do is we
augment the point analysis and feel
doesn't think much of an augmentation
really takes I think three or four
different 30 for additional point
analysis rules
and there is essentially model these put
and get operations within cash maps in a
more precise manner so that we only have
flow between values associated with the
same key of a nap okay and i'll show how
this helps us a bit later on okay so let
me summarize what we've done on the
front of pointy nails so this is kind of
a hierarchy so as far as context
sensitivity we are doing pretty well so
what we're implementing is essentially
infinite ccv which is actually quite a
precise version context sensitivity with
objects with respect to objects in
sativa t we are not doing nearly as
great we are doing something that can be
characterized as partial one level
object sensitivity but only applied to
certain location sites but it gives us
the results you want it's far as lab
sensitivity we are only doing constant
keys because this is what we found to be
important the experiments but one might
imagine doing much more precise symbolic
type of analysis of key values and so on
it was flow sensitivity well our our
point analysis natively supports sort of
natural and distance local flow it
doesn't refuse you know because this
local SS a representation within method
so it doesn't confuse values there now
what we have totally oblivious to is
predicates we are not looking at
predicted values at all and that's to
contrast with what some with what some
of the other groups tried and again we
didn't really find pretty good
information to be very valuable in our
experiments and that is I should also
point out that the analysis we are doing
is essentially global whole program
fully interprocedural analysis yep
Austin keys and local po seem to be
sweet spots for the application to look
that is that also true for the one level
object sensitivity because I could see
going beyond one level my yeah so I
would be cautious of making that claim I
think there is quite a bit of allocation
side bearing happening can some of these
things so you have a factor Egypt down
and you push out
so I'm not making that claim i think
object sensitivity SL discusses very
important still yeah so you get more
about what is local flow sensitive is
this your terminology i see the standard
one and is this just sse conversion or
is it more than that it just as a second
version i mean basically so if you have
I mean did the way something very simple
so they did the way to understand it is
that you essentially have kind of a what
they call the three address
representation for there for there for
the methods right so basically to make
sure that that registers whose life
ranges or a sort of unrelated don't get
confused that's basically there's
nothing more than that here this much
more sensitivity kareena for these kinds
of applications or would he have gained
more yes our sense is that I'll talk
about that yeah that's exactly our sams
so okay now having just described the
point analysis let me talk about let me
give you a little bit of a glimpse of
what's going on sort of in the bowels of
the system if you will and this is just
the glimpse I guess so what what we
start with is the pickle query this is
the same example that we had that I have
on you know several slides ago now this
pickle query is translated into agreeing
in data log magically so there is a
syntax director to a way to do
translation to datalog catalog is this
logic programming language and it's been
used among other things for point
analysis tasks I'm sorry for program
analysis tasks now this career in data
log is fed into a daily log solver so
this data log solver is something that's
been developed within our group and we
used it for variety of applications and
this this is among them
so out of the dialogue cells where we
kind of get two sets of results the
first one is a list of relevant
instrumentation points this is something
we'll use for runtime a bit later on
I'll show you where that goes and the
second one which is something we've been
after all along is vulnerability warning
warning so vulnerable to traces and the
vulnerability traces I essentially given
to the user in a way that they can sort
of browse through them and understand
what the steps are essentially it's a
bunch of traces from a source this thing
with some objects in between and so that
maps directly to what we have here right
so we have in this case it trades
consisting of four different objects and
the user can go and look and examine the
code and figure out what's going on okay
so let me come back to the issue of
soundness I really want to beat this
point to death now soundness is kind of
the only way to for us to provide
guarantees about the security posture of
an application which is what you like in
grainger another advantage of soundness
is that it allows us to remove
instrumentation points in our intent
instrumentation points without
jeopardizing their own protection that
we have at wrong time now here's the
claim we have for as far as some this is
concerned our analysis finds all
vulnerabilities in statically analyzed
code that are captured by the
specification okay well sounds great now
there are two cables to this let me show
you what they are first the first one is
this so we need to figure out what the
static the analyzed and the second one
is that which is captured by the
specification as you pointed out if the
specification is lagging certain methods
you know portions then we have no way to
know what to look for so both of these
are kind of substantial problems let me
talk about the first one which is an
extension of our static technology but
before I do that let me actually sort of
step go back one step and talk about so
how generally these
our static analysis in Java operate
sedative able to analyze the whole
application we need to know what the
call graph is like now the way this
works typically is that we specify a
bunch of routes and then there is a
coger discovery process that runs so
there are a bunch of edges that are by a
bunch of college is being followed here
until be really fixed point in this
process in this exploration okay and
well so remember this picture now here's
what the architecture of a typical web
I'm saying typical application server
with applications on top of it looks
like right so we have the application
services sitting here and then we have a
bunch of application alongside each
other now any of these applications can
be pickups health million lines of code
counting the libraries the application
services jboss this is actually pretty
precise number when it counted it's
about 1.5 million lines of code combined
together this is over 2 million lines of
code to analyze and remember we are
talking about global and hopefully
precise males so this is a pretty
difficult challenge we have on our hands
so we'd like to avoid it as much as
possible so fortunately there is a trick
the trick consists of this entry
consists of looking at this little web
that XML thing so what that XML is a
deployment descriptor or to put it
differently a contract between what the
application server expects and what the
application provides and it's usually
the piece of XML looks like this okay um
now essentially what we do is we parse
this XML descriptor and we generate a
harness that proceeds to invoke
different parts different parts of the
web application application in turn like
this I'm not showing the details of that
but you can sort of imagine it iterating
called over over the servlets and so on
now this is a much sort of an
oops much better deal we have because we
essentially only analyzed about healthy
million lines of code on account and a
bit on top of that but it's still
possible now this is kind of as far as
finding the roots ok so this harness
essentially provides roots for our
analysis remember the second sort of big
piece of the puzzle was discovering the
call graph yeah effectively you know so
it's it's so instead of the calls from
there so the alternative would be
discharged with the main method of the
application server internalize it sort
of from the bottom all the way up to the
application and in this car in this case
we are catching it at this level and
that's the harness now the second piece
of the puzzle as I started sort of
alluding to was we need to be able to
discover the call graph now there have
been numerous methods for numerous
algorithms for cole graff resolution in
object oriented code all those
unfortunately have avoided issue of
reflection and deflection it turns out
is actually very common in logic and
debris applications this is the ones you
can in Java and there are multiple sort
of reasons why one would want to have
reflection in place including closing
plug-in code avoids you can create
incompatibilities and so on so this
example over here is actually something
that tries to create a class over here
that's only something you can do on Mac
OS 10 and then if that fails then there
is a different you know there's
different processing codes invoked now
just focus on this for now right so we
create the class and then we creating
your instance of that class so there's a
pattern here so the better looks like
this so we get the class name from
somewhere could be constant could be
something else we create a class object
out of that class name we proceed to
create a new instance of the class on
line three and then we cast it to some
useful type and proceed to do
think with it afterwards now the
question a natural question to ask here
is what object is created with your
online three well there are kind of
several ways to go about answering that
question the first one is to figure out
what class name is so this is a strange
so where does it come from well there
are two potential answers to that could
be constant in which case we are golden
we know what classes are being generated
over here on line three or it could be a
specification point a specification
point is the place in the program where
user input is required to fully resolve
this construct okay so when everything
is a constant then there is no input
that's needed once there are
specification points the user so
basically we apply a little bit of
porringer analysis here still and
backtrack essentially we tell the user
where this class name comes from and
it's typical for it to come from files
from you know from the network from
whatever from inputted so on but at
least we are able to tell the user where
the specification is necessary to fully
construct the kilogram so this is one
approach and by the way both of this
approach and others are summarized in
our paper in m plus 2005 the second
approach is to pay attention to what's
going on in line for so we have a class
or we have a cast rather online for now
assuming we know what all the subclasses
of class t are it could end assuming of
course also that this cast doesn't fail
we are we can conclude that the object
late though here in line three is only
one of the subclasses okay so this is
sometimes in precise but this gives us a
way to get a upper limit of evil on what
could be constructed on line three over
here so a combination of these two
approaches actually proves to be quite
effective so here are some numbers so we
applied this reflection resolution
technology technique
a set of techniques rather to a set of
six large java benchmark applications
almost two hundred thousand lines of
code combined so this is what we observe
so this is the blue bar is kind of
before with no reflection resolution
whatsoever and the greenish bar is the
after picture which is with full
reflection resolution enabled so as you
can see across the board there are
pretty significant increases in the size
of the call graph here the counting the
number of melon seems to be pretty easy
way to count decisive the cold grab now
for some of the applications like this
one for instance J gap the size of the
cold graph increases as much as seven
fold from the version that we have over
here that does no reflection resolution
to the one that does fully recovered
from the solution so the takeaway
message here I think is that when we
sort of pay attention to reflection the
Colegrove sizes the cold graphs increase
the grid go2 put it differently if we
our believe is the leadership reflection
we are ending up missing a large
fraction of the program okay so let me
switch gears now and talk about the
runtime analysis portion of this work
okay so let me remind you what the
situation is so this situation is this
we had the applications you're in terms
of byte code and we have some sort of
vulnerability specification these things
are combined together to produce an
instrument the security version of the
application over here and this secured
version is deployed alongside other
unsecured application in the standard
application server and just runs as well
now do I central to or ways in which
this can be used the first one is we are
detect the potential vulnerability than
if the potential exploit going through
and we stop with all the application the
second mode which is much much active
for many scenarios is with it detect the
application and we are able to recover
from it and we give the user the
opportunity to provide
cobra code for us as we'll see shortly
now the way our instrumentation is done
is actually in a pretty generic fashion
so the big wall specification is
combined is converted into a series of a
set of state machines that run alongside
the program that is instrumented and on
as I mentioned before recovery code can
run before image is detected so there's
some sort of a starting event and then
there are other events that being
observed and what happens at each point
in this picture is that partial measures
are being collected so some of the
partial matches will never lead anywhere
but some of the partial matches will
essentially lead us to complete match so
insten area number one we stop the
application completely in scenario
number two we have some sort of
sanitization code that we're on before
we allow this sort of flow to go through
and then we should have complete this
process now let me talk about sort of
the final piece of the puzzle here which
is reducing the instrumentation overhead
something you were asking before about
before so this is the same old people
clearly I've been showing here all along
now just pay attention to this matches
part over here right this is the thing
that has to sort of happen at runtime
imagine a piece of code looking like
this so basically there is a static
analysis that runs in figures out which
of these are statements over here can
participate in the match and in this
case this code will be able to conclude
successfully that only four out of seven
statements over here I could be part of
a match and the other three are just not
instrumented at all now as I mentioned
before soundness is something that
allows us to safely remove
instrumentation points without the fear
of sort of compromising the security of
the runtime system
okay so having described that let me now
focus on experimental results again so
there are two are suites of experimental
I'm saying over benchmarks that we use
for our experiments the first one
consists of 11 large benchmarks so there
are quite substantial obligations when
we call the libraries and all the other
stuff this is how much could we get over
3 million lines of code for the big ones
there's also a suite of a bit of a 100
micro synthetic benchmarks that I just
wrote for the purpose of essentially you
know testing our techniques and they
contain quite a bit less code now we get
a sort of we collect information from
our work from the Griffin project as far
as both of these sets of benchmarks are
concerned oh by the way I forget to
mention that you know these are publicly
available and we have a workshop paper
and these if you're interested now in
addition to doing that we also have
something else which is very able to get
a commercial commercial to that that is
designed to look for some of the same
problems if we're able to run the
commercial to alongside of alongside our
approach into I'll show you some of the
comparisons a little bit later so this
tool is called CODIS sure produced by
secure software out in Virginia and
these people were nice enough to allow
us to sort of show these use also i'm
very grateful to them now okay so here's
some statistics as far as the large
benchmarks are concerned so to give you
some idea what some of these benchmarks
are many of these are bloggers
applications all sort of large
infrastructures for creating blogs i
guess so something interesting to look
at here is the sizes of these
applications so this is the number of
lines of code in the application code
itself over here and this is the
expanded number of lines of code what I
mean by that is that when we
count when we look at the call graph as
discovered by our analysis and when we
count the lines of code within their
libraries as well as the application we
get a picture it looks like this so the
lines of code of the application itself
kind of our about that of fifty thousand
lines of code something like that but
the amount of code actually analyzed is
quite a bit higher than that so in the
biggest of our benchmarks roller the
amount of lines of code analyzed was
over Calvin million so I think it's
important here to be aware of this
difference between the application lines
of code and the lines of code it
analyzed now uh-oh so these are the
results okay cool so this is this is
what they find when we run a sort of our
techniques on these benchmarks we find
close to 100 vulnerabilities all
together now there's only one of the
benchmarks that exhibits false positives
and actually it has quite a number of
them and I'll speak to that issue in a
moment so one of the applications has
false positives one however the cell oh
and here's a classification of the
vulnerabilities we're fine so there is
so the way this classification works is
that there are sources of data the
number of techniques in this arena and
there are things again there are a
number of there's quite a variety over
here so become the most common issue is
actually the one that I got in is an
example before which is sequel injection
caused by parameter manipulation this is
the highest number in this table but
there are other possibilities is well
such as past reversal and cross site
scripting and the like now we reported
these issues back to program being in
years and most of them were actually
sort of very nice to work with and most
of the vulnerabilities were confirmed
and fixed in later versions of the code
and we got some vulnerability advisors
advisor estrada issued for this
take about that as well let me now talk
a little bit about the micro benchmarks
that we have here so the way this works
is that there are different categories
for the micro benchmarks as you can see
that as you can see there are benchmarks
that go after the handling of
collections for instance their
benchmarks that test the handling of
India procedural code there are things
that have to do with point aliasing and
data structure and Lincoln Strunk
updates and so okay in particular what
I'm emphasizing here is that for
instance are we are finding sort of all
the vulnerabilities our technique is
conservative since finding all the
vulnerabilities present for instance for
these two classes of benchmarks but at
the same time the fact that we are not
disambiguating between array elements
and we are totally oblivious to
predicates means that else reporting a
number of false positives on both of
these fronts of you will now none of
them seem to be very important in large
application are in large applications so
i just wanted to point out something
that seemed to be important on based on
our experience with small ones small
benchmarks but not large ones ok so
we've spent so much time be think I'll
beefing up our point analysis in our
static analysis technology well did it
pay off let me give you an example of
what happens so this is one of the sort
of medium-sized application from the
sort of real light lower real life
benchmark sleep so here are some
statistics at the ball it's about fifty
thousand lines of code it has almost 400
classes and has 40 sources has almost
cities things it has it actually
contains six confirmed vulnerabilities
now what I'd like to discuss here is
false positive so when we when we have
sort of a totally dumb analysis that is
not context-sensitive no nothing
essentially that's our base number we
get 114 false positive
when we apply for context sensitivity we
get it down to about it but we'll do 284
when we apply object sensitivity
improvements we get it down to 43 when
we apply map sensitivity forget it down
to five and finally when we add portions
of the original specifications that
we're missing when we started we get it
down to zero so as you can see here all
of these sort of precision improvements
that we've been working so hard to put
in actually pay off at least in some of
the applications and there's this
interesting interplay between them but
all of them proved to be necessary at
some point okay now so let's talk about
the issue of false positives and false
negatives because well let's just do
that okay so here's something I'd like
you to focus on so so this is the these
are the macro benchmarks and these are
the micro benchmarks now what we are
summarizing here's number of
vulnerabilities first of all and we're
comparing the results we get from the
griffin project which is all work from
there comparing them to the results we
get from Kadesh sure which is that a
commercial tool that we will are using
so Griffin is shown in blue and coda
sure is shown in green or greenish now
as you can see across the board for both
the big benchmarks and the little ones
we get we find considerably more
vulnerabilities with our approach then
they do with koda sure now that's great
we like that very much right because we
have a conservative static analysis
technique now something that's not so
great is that we also have more false
positives in this case that single
application actually bumps up the number
of false positives we report quite a bit
now their number for politics is
actually very low across the board it's
actually though
it's considerable lower in the case of
micro benchmarks because they make these
various or precision improvements to
their analysis yeah because I guess to
run your tool you need these
vulnerabilities specifications there's
the quota sure tool take the same spec
sir well we put this one right so that's
that's actually a valid question and so
basically they don't have well obviously
they don't have the same sort of input
format if you go it seems like the range
of vulnerabilities by just looking at
the tool and sort of they have a way to
select which ones to look at seems to be
a similar in fact there's is actually
super set of ours because they're also
looking for some stylistic issues and
some memory leaks perhaps and someday
Teresa's well so we then compare across
those types of scenarios but I it seems
that they're looking at the same types
of issues as far as the web application
vulnerabilities are concerned but there
is no way to know for sure whether it's
I mean it's point well taken i think now
so a different way to interpret these
results is that our code assure
essentially reports a bunch of false
negatives right so while our approach is
conservative and suffers from false
positives there's is in a way optimistic
and suffers from false negatives and
when it comes to security or the point
here is that it's important to be
conservative but I think it's a point I
made already so you know that now let's
talk about something else which is so
there's this sort of controversy about
shallow bogs versus more deep bugs and
how difficult box other financial so let
me to speak a little bit to that ish so
one way to get at this is by looking at
the length of vulnerability traces be
fine so here's a histogram beach for
each so remember from the static
analysis we get there we get a bunch of
traces that essentially sequences of
lists of objects right
so for our each length of a trace we
count the number of traces that we
encountered in a large benchmark so you
can see here something that is rather
surprising creatures there's actually
preach a large number of trees that are
quite long and this is something we
found we weren't really expecting so
it's natural to sort of have a bunch of
shadow problems you can probably find
with you know sort of grab or something
like that but it turns out that there
actually are problems that are quite a
bit more profound and the longer traces
are typically the more difficult it is
to find with manual inspection that's
the point here now there is something
else here which is suppose I discount
all the library code suppose I move that
I mean I take it out of consideration
the picture changes so without the
library code being considered said the
longest race is actually seven or so so
it's a common pattern for these problems
to actually be a nesting if you build in
deep inside library code as you'll see
on ya know some of objects right so a
trace is object one object to object the
object then you take n and edit the
histogram the other data point which I'm
sort of skipping over here is that there
might be multiple ways to get to the
city if you have a source in the sink
there are oftentimes multiple paths that
take you there that's another sort of
factor there you have my question ok
fine so libraries right ok now del gets
to sort of this other issue which is
what is the connectivity between sources
and sinks and so here's a picture of a
spaceship now here's a picture of a
graph that we extract from sort of one
of these benchmarks when we apply our
static tools to it called personal blog
so the things on the left over here our
sources and the things on the right of
sinks and you
okay and sort of each of these little
dots is an object or a static
representation of an object right
remember is everything here so far is
static now there is more structure in
this as you can probably guess so here
is the structure so this little portion
over here corresponds to the application
curve this portion over here which is
actually very tightly connected is
library codes in this case this is the
hibernate library librarians used our be
quite a large number of Joyce java
application for resistance purposes and
this little locationally here is in an
injection vector so this in particular
is something called session than fine
which is emitted in the public epi stat
takes a string this eventually passed to
a bag debt bacon database actually there
are quite a number of ways for it to go
to the backend database as you can see
from here but the fact that this method
is an injection vector is never
advertised so there is no way for the
use of this library of this little up
for this application like your personal
blog to know that they need to sanitize
values that go into this API net okay
now while be able to deal with personal
blog quite nicely we are not able to
deal with this other with this other
this other benchmark controller quite so
nicely so what happens within the roller
is that it actually happens to use the
same hibernate library as personal blog
does now it uses different a very entry
points from personal blog it what
happens is that there is some are fully
tainted object that sort of no matter
what we do no matter sort of how much
our call graph cloning we apply we were
unable to make it undated if you will
and so that leads to a large number of
false
vulnerability path right so essentially
this one object is responsible since you
see the connectivity here to be like
this if you have an object sitting over
here that's false the thing that it will
be connected to large number of six in
potential large number of sources as
well which leads to this multiplicative
explosion problem in the number of false
positives now what please do our
advantage of course is that if you know
the structure of the problem you know
how sources and sinks are conducted if
you kind of instead of just giving lists
back to the user figure it if we give
them a graph or some sort of other
hierarchical representation then the
user has a much better chance of
figuring out sooner that certain things
are false positives so I think this is
something we need to take advantage of
here yep false positives and you go to
each other it's hard so in this case we
kind of we know we knew how to group it
and then basically I because I mean you
know I really wanted to get to the
bottom of this one in particular I
basically separated the I figured out
the entry points to the library
separated the library wrote a wrap
around it and just stopped in the
debugger to see what path are taken seem
to be the most busiest way to do it but
of course nothing that the user would
welcome as you can probably guess it's
not excess of the easiest sometimes to
figure out whether something is a false
positive or not yeah well so yeah the
issue of counting so there are many ways
to go about and people have sort of
tried different approaches and on in
this case we are just counting
combinations of the counting sourcing
pairs as as one we're not if we were
counting past and things that are very
very sort of roughly the same thing what
becomes it is multiple ones that you
hear that the number of pairs roughly
very roughly approximates the amount of
manual effort one has to invest to
inspect these results right because I
mean like I said because of this sort of
joint connectivity among pal let the
approach we chose but the alternative to
this as well okay no sort of the
long-forgotten runtime analysis well so
here's what happens here so we basically
installed a bunch of these applications
on in a standard application server
there instrumented versions were
installed and we are first of all the
first sort of sanity check if he really
took some of the some of the results we
got from static analysis and turn them
into exploits and we run these exploits
against these are instrumented
obligations and we are happy to say that
we are able to block and recover from
these exploits at runtime so that's the
let's think number one then the next
interesting question to look at is the
question of runtime overhead so what
happens here is that well the nave
implementation essentially end sub
instrumenta kriti much every string
operation there is in the program and
trust me there are a lot of string
operations so the overhead can be
somewhat significant so as you can see
here for instance for web code the
overhead is more than twice right so one
hundred forty percent on top of the
original execution
and for some of the others it's around
maybe forty percent or so now when we
apply when they compute static
information and reduce the number of
instrumentation points the number of the
first of the number of instrumentation
points drops considerably sometimes to
almost one percent of the number of IGM
instrumentation points but secondly of
course the runtime overhead is reduced
dramatically as well so in this case or
rollers out winner with the runtime
overhead being or pretty much negligible
but in other in other cases there on
time overhead is also quite quite good
so what to go ahead we have something
about forty percent and as I mentioned
before these are interactive
applications for their overhead is not
as significant as it would be in a batch
type or server type in the market okay
so
let me go go Oh first of all let me
summarize the contribution so I think
you know this by now but we just sort of
emphasize a couple of points here so I
think what's been driving this research
to large extent is the desire to solve
the large important real life problem
out there and we essentially came up
with a hybrid approach to do that which
consists of aesthetic analysis and
focusing on static analysis technology
allowed us to boost technology quite a
bit earlier than it was pushed before in
particular material point analysis
precision as well as scalability and
also looking at features of modern
obligations such as reflection or the
other aspect of this was smart random
technology and some of the ability to
providing the ability to recover from
exploits at runtime so moving towards
better more friendly runtime environment
has been the theme for that and finally
be sort of drove a lot of this with a
large scale experimental validation of
our techniques which first of all like I
said allows us to push the techniques
quite a bit and let us do the discovery
of a large number of previously unknown
vulnerabilities which is always a good
thing so as far as the related work well
there is a great deal of related work in
the field of bug finding a software
verification I'm not really going to
cover them because that would take me
quite in quite a long time let me sell
is it talked a little bit on the on the
subject of penetration testing as well
as application firewalls that are some
of the commonly used techniques in this
chair is far as web application security
is concerned so people have applied on
various testing technologies to that
now there are several projects that were
inspiring at the time we started our
project which was the web sorry work
that was done in the context of PHP
essentially the techniques they are
quite a bit difference a pitch be the
scripting language and the technology
there needs to be sort of appropriate
for the language that analyzing now
there is no sort of soundness guarantees
that they're making and but still I mean
they found it to be quite effective what
for what develop you get there are a
couple of other projects sort of for
instance the JDBC checker project was
kind of an interesting project is
focused on our precisely analyzing all
sort of statically figuring out values
that can be part of jealous James but
again we think we think that the focus
there is a little bit misplaced I think
we've been able to figure follow strings
precisely I think that's kind of most of
the problem right there now what
happened is that we were actually lucky
enough to publish a lot of our world to
publish that of the big two papers in
the Griffin project quite a bit you know
pretty early on in early 2005 and what
happened it lists sort of academically
speaking is that there was an explosion
in the number of papers that came after
that so we got a lot of citations out of
that work so people have sort of looked
at various extension of runtime
technology people have also looked at
including some groups at Stanford looked
at analyzing PHP and other types of all
types of form scripting scripting
languages people have even looked at
better or grind site protection
technology so instrumenting to the
following a javascript in the browser it
seemed to be actually a pretty
profitable you know pretty interesting
idea two tries people have looked at
that quite a bit so there's a URL if
you're interested so there's you know
the amount of work in this in this area
is still small enough to fit in one
piece
okay so let me let me talk about some of
the some of the projects that sort of
naturally emerge from this style of
research so these bars over here
indicate the sort of progress if you go
I know how to measure progress but this
is my best sort of intuitive gasps so
one of the areas in which we made quite
a bit of progress actually is applying
model checking technology to some of the
same issues now the focus of my work has
largely been on sort of what happens
when there is a single HTTP request that
comes down the line and goes into the
application something happens to it now
there might be other interesting issues
that happen when you have multiple
interacting HTTP requests that the
application receives or they might be D
that is preserved from previous requests
that is affecting the current one so
this is what model checking technology
is believed to be attracting another
sort of good feature of this model
checking technologies that essentially
it's able to drive full exploit traces
so we know we run the model check it
comes back with the answer and the
answer is essentially Oh a snapshot of
every turn through the application code
and that actually makes it very easy to
explain to the user what went wrong
unlike our approach with actually
requires a little bit on the part of the
user to sort of figure out what the flow
of data is locally another interesting
area in which we meet also quite a bit
of progress is learning specifications
from a runtime data history so our
experience has been that it's common
especially in object oriented systems to
have a single piece of data that is it
might be contained in an object at one
time but is then extracted or permuted
in some way and put into another object
and if you look at that piece of data
are across time I think you will learn
quite a bit about what valid and invalid
behavior might be so people have looked
at have looked at method calls for
instance applied this single object and
try to construct our state machines that
describe and capture that sort of
interaction and so that work has been
quite successful but we believe that we
can go quite a bit further if you focus
sort of on our data acid my grades from
one object to the next now as far as the
program analysis sort of the
underpinnings of the program and
analysis technology is concerned I think
there's quite a bit of interesting work
still to be done so I mentioned before
the data log saw the name of the data
log solvers be dbgb and we applied it in
out within our group to a lot of
interesting static analysis problems but
now I think we're at the point where we
don't really have a good way to scale it
anymore so basically some of the
problems we threw it at lately have been
essentially hitting the limits of that
technology and there are different ways
to go about that one of them is sort of
this other project will be started which
is using partition BDDs to scale the
solver and let me just give you a
glimpse of that sibilities the idea
there is that you essentially achieve
higher levels of compression when you
have information that has a lot of
commonality in it now in order to do
that we need to figure out how to do
bdts upgrade on large large big mid
vectors and we need to tell the BCD
package what order the vectors into p.m.
now the problem is that there is no
globally good order and often happens
that if you separate the problems into
chunks and if you're on the chunks on
sub word processors you'll be able to
find locally best orders on those
processors and enjoy the process
practices will complete sooner and then
you
be able to combine the results it was
thus the hope and there's been
interesting technology developed at
fujitsu labs that are applied this
technologies this separation sort of
technique successfully to our hardware
tasks we'd like to adapt some of this to
this problem as well there are armed let
me see which ones really pick so okay
let me just do want to mention one more
of these in then we can go to the
question so this one for instance is so
the way we've been doing analysis lately
in our group is bikes essentially in a
declarative fashion just we take the
input program we represent it as a set
of relations it's essentially database
and then we have a data log program that
constructs relations out of the input
relations which are stored in the
database now when we finish the process
when the data log set of three runs we
have the results and then if able to
classify the results as false positives
and two positives then perhaps we can go
back to each and revisit each individual
decision that we made sort of in within
this process and figure out whether it
was a good decision or not so if you
have an Oracle that tells us what are
the false positives are we can go back
and figure out what the sources from
precision or and pickups learn where
there's best to enhance the precision of
the analysis in the first place and
there are many other things which I'm
going to skip so let me um this is
pretty much all I have so these are some
of the relevant urls for the griffin
security project and then some of the
benchmarks well actually all of the
benchmarks effect and then the picu
language which I'm kind of downplaying
because it's the work of my code and
they're also sort of papers on some of
these things
I'm out of water too yes so I'm we're so
familiar with the area of web
applications but did you ever run into
the problem of concurrency or Marty
sighting yeah well so the point analysis
we are used is flowing sensitive so it's
essentially vs to the ordering of the
statements behalf in the program so we
didn't it wasn't really even industry
for us today so i'm guessing SS a1 or
outline love my very good point um
well so it's the same sort of the same
set of assumptions that the pointy
analysis essentially using oh I know the
only to sort of think about this is aja
a little bit there might be something
there there's not this office yeah the
place that when your techniques is into
a language it's not tight well so we did
a project in C make sure one of the
things mentioned here that was looking
at format string of all abilities
informants I'm sorry and buffer overruns
and the idea there was essentially
similar which is used statically analyze
stained and well the flavor of point
analysis ends up being very very
different so even though you can
imaginary using many of the same to the
framework features if you go the
underpinnings are very very different so
it's it really applies to I think this
technique applies best two types of
languages and to the flavor of point
analysis that has a clear distinction
between the variables in heap objects
because in see there is really no such
thing and you have structs like we did
on the understand you have got an eighth
nasty aspects of the language that
really make it quite a bit harder to
penalize and that results in a worse
precision sort of down the line if you
want to be conservative of course but we
could call a couple of ways to do point
analysis and see one which was fully
conservative if you will and the other
one was a bit more optimistic and we
kind of define what it means but for the
optimistic one yeah you essentially get
more precision but this is what the
usual attention is there
yep I understand a little bit more about
your interest in using more regional for
web applications when here using this
information flow analysis with a fancy
pointer analysis and you as you should
that the number of false positives are
spoing clear so before taking do you
want to cut down these false positives
or are you looking at more digitally
specifications well I think the focus
there is slightly different it's love my
projects I can do a fully speak for it
but first of all so I mentioned a couple
of things right so one of them is so
they're having a full trace over an
exploit and they actually being able to
craft and exploit which we give to the
program meeting dangers of extremely
high value right because I mean
basically the way you do this stuff is
that you sort of stare at the step at
what you get statically and then you end
up sort of coming up with exploit
yourself so if instead of that you had a
full automatic way to have an exploit
perhaps also with the value that would
explore it which is actually the focus
of that research finding the values that
would be able to exploit that such as
that it's actually fully aware of the
you know the branches in the program and
the value Deseret branch so that by
itself is of great importance open times
now the other thing is that we were sort
of limiting our scope a bit we
were sort of looking at a model in which
we have a single request arriving and
then the idea is that if you have
interactions of multiple requests as you
typically have in the running web
application then you might have these
interesting corner cases one user would
play something in a global data
structure which would a later stage
would be consumed or place attainted
value in a global data structure we
would which would be consumed by
somebody unknowingly pulling out of the
data structure right so you can see you
can see that playing out as well but I
think to do most of the focuses on
coming coming up with investing exploit
values and there's been a lot of
interest sort of in Stanford in those
nine
let's go for instance and coming up with
sort of inputs that crash the
application so we're looking at some of
that same some of those same problems
over here so sanitizers for instance is
an interesting curious so this story
there is that say lasers are essentially
most of them are routines that they
could drink in the jonas chain if the
stimulate return is some derivation some
variation on the original one they would
filter some of the characters they would
do some other things in the problem is
that essentially in order to do this
right since we have thinking but pretty
much in all these applications or
applications writers end up writing
sanitizers and there are no good
standards as to how to do that so
everybody ends up improvising and pretty
much everybody with only a few
exceptions gets it wrong it's actually a
very challenging test to do it because
there are different complications such
as n coatings that the input takes and
make it making sure that you use the
right set of characters and that you use
whitelisting instead of blacklisting and
so on it's quite a challenging problem
turns out and in in some of the cases so
for some of the problems we found we
ended up essentially constructing
exploits that went around to some of the
sanitizers they got in the first place
so this imposition that was there was
insufficient that's part of the reason
why delegating specification to the user
because we cannot really ensure
sensation in any good way but on the
other hand model checking seems to be a
suitable approach to breaking sanitizers
in the other thing is that we can
actually afford to have a great deal of
precision because some more sanitizers
actually wear itself contains contained
sort of pieces of quarter if you're
interested I can show you a couple and
all depends upon it okay sure cable
further questions and